mitten in berlin liegt der große
tiergarten die grüne lunge der stadt
weithin sichtbar die siegessäule
spitznamen goldelse in ihrem mercedes
cabriolet baujahr 1969 mit kerstin flüge
ihre gäste wie marketing spezialisten
bietet seit zehn rundfahrten an
in einem offenen auto ganzheitlich
erleben und sein wie man so schön sagt
180 grad rundumblick haben und nicht
irgendwelche dach über sich oder neben
sich haben sie bekommen einen ganz
anderen eindruck von den gebäuden und
von der schönheit der stadt die stadt
nun fragten im oldtimer cabrio gestaltet
kersting flüge in absprache mit ihren
gästen abholung am wunschort inklusive
am brandenburger tor waren allen well
und werner baumgarten das paar kommt aus
neuss in nordrhein westfalen berlin
steht schon lange auf der wunschliste
vor wenigen jahren würden vollen platz
in so einem schönen auto in berlin für
das paar geht es zunächst ins
nahegelegene regierungsviertel
die fahrt führt vorbei am holocaust
mahnmal und am sowjetischen ehrenmal
dann öffnet sich der blick auf das
reichstagsgebäude
die gläserne kuppel stammt von
stararchitekt norman foster
reichstagsgebäude mit den bossen
parlamentes von 25 eröffnete bildung der
zweite sagte nannte das ganze ding
einfach nur klasse wurde weil er mit
parlamentarismus und der demokratischen
entwicklung in deutschland in so viel am
hut hat wir sehen können war das gebäude
vorher nicht wirklich anders aus und war
dann doch sehr stark zerstört gegenüber
vom reichstag liegt das bundeskanzleramt
acht mal so groß wie das weiße haus in
washington
nächstes ziel ist die museumsinsel in
berlins historischer mitte
der komplex aus bode tangermann altem
und neuem museum sowie der alten
nationalgalerie gehört zum unesco
welterbe
das ganze auch vorne mit der
museumsinsel ist eines der größten seen
auf der welt die ihm selber beherbergt
museum mit der nofretete und dem
pergamon altar als wesentlichen aspekt
der berliner dom darunter uta und kroos
für der hohenzollern und das ganze mit
abgerundeten form dinge im umfang der
parade mit den messdaten am
gendarmenmarkt zeigt die berliner mitte
ein weiteres mal ihre architektonische
brachte der platz mit dem konzerthaus
den deutschen und den französischen dom
zählt zu den schönsten in deutschland
erst mit flöte steuert ihrem mercedes
richtung charlie den berühmten
grenzübergang in einst geteilten berlin
berlin immer noch nicht so ganz neu
gestaltet hat man es sich eigentlich mit
werden soll weil es doch eine halbe
ereignet fight war ihm der das ganze
hier stattgefunden habe und vor allem
für die berliner bürger selber natürlich
auch hoch dramatisch war kein besuch
ohne original berliner campus erfunden
haben will sie die astronomen herta
heuwer im jahr 1909 das geschmacks
geheimnis steckt in der in berlin offen
oder westen
das highlight war aber ich denke auch
das ist eine ordentliche weite
schmeckt sehr hoher im berliner
stadtbild ist die einstige teilung kaum
noch zu sehen
einige wenige überreste der berliner
mauer stehen bis heute in der
niederkirchnerstraße am potsdamer platz
zeigt berlin sein modernes gesicht mehr
als 100 meter ragen forum kollhoff und
bahn tower in die höhe
kaum vorstellbar dass hier einst ein
riesiges niemandsland war mit mauer und
todesstreifen wir index die stadt uns
hat es war der wunderschöne tour
wunderschöner tag
ich denke wir werden das noch mal machen
weil berlin hat eine größe hat mir super
gut gefallen berlin ist eine
wunderschöne stadt und ich bin einfach
fasziniert und ich denke dass wenn wir
auf jeden fall wiederholen
wir freuen sich die beiden aber erst
einmal auf angemessen so in einem der
vielen cafés